on this episode we talk about headlines
self-awareness and why your dad showed
up on Instagram
[Music]
this is
ask Gary B
[Music]
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 102 of the ask gary
vee show so last night was a long night
I got some four dinners and an after
party business networking got home at
4:15 in the morning so a little bit more
tired than normal happy Memorial Day
everybody
in the US and happy weekend to everybody
outside the US India let's get into the
show I love that part for some reason
it's like my favorite part of the show
it said like literally it's gonna
eventually be like oh I'm gonna I'm
gonna just start coming up with
different
d-roc stop trying to like force the show
there's such a over producer alright
India let's get into the show Brendan
wants to know what kind of headlines
attract you on social media that's a
great question I think the the
interesting part about this question is
I think a lot of different headlines
attract me and I think the headline copy
reading called the BuzzFeed
application of media is fully in play
now I mean when you go look with a
cynical yes they'll be fun to ask Steve
this question it probably hurts you're
actually not that's not true I'm curious
what your take is on the fact that like
the New York Times now does this right
like like literally the whole world has
gone slant slang and five you know ways
to do this like it's all a headline copy
marketing it's the stuff I built Wine
Library on on email marketing headlines
it's just become the game I'm not quite
sure exactly what's grabbing my
attention usually it's around the
subject matter so usually things that
scare me like Jets running backs in
trouble oh no you know like so but I I'm
not sure but the reason I wanted to
answer the question is because I think
it's very important for everybody who's
watching the show I know a lot of people
here are go-getters entrepreneurs
and and do-gooders whether you're trying
to raise money for your charity or
whether you're trying to sell a boat for
the winter you need to really think
about the copy on everything you put out
it is an absolute variable to success
you can follow all the structural advice
that I'm giving you but when you get to
writing the copy on a Facebook post or a
Pinterest post or on Twitter if you're
not good at that if you're not good at
grabbing someone's attention you're in
big trouble and so I'm not sure what's
grabbing my attention but I know that
the person behind writing it is doing a
good job that's how you answer the
question without answering the question
by bringing value by bringing value to
your audience not by dodging Steve no
know that you laugh your laugh was like
yeah all right let's go princess
why is Twitter so much like a wall in a
public bathroom Bruce this is a
tremendous question I think the I would
argue that it's not I would argue that
secret was more like a public bathroom
because you don't know who wrote it and
I think that what's scarier probably by
your rant is that people are actually
putting their faces behind these
comments that you think are so lame or
interesting or aggressive or however
you're positioning it so I would argue
that they're not I think that they're
the Twitter is much more like you know a
cocktail party where people are just
making statements or a gathering of
friends or you know less of the bathroom
stall that to me that's secret and all
the other anonymous Yik yak and all the
other anonymous plays that's more of the
psychology you write something that
nobody can attribute to you bathroom
business jargon people say in business
simply one of the great black and white
and blue hoods a scary show these are
loving this right all right tagline Tom
wants to know what are some easy ways to
become more self-aware tagline Tom
I think there's one hack for becoming
more self-aware which is asking people
around you and creating a safe zone a
permission for them to actually tell you
about you from their perspective and
it's on you to create that safe place so
that they actually tell you things that
you may not want to hear because what I
think could happen is that you get
chipped away at and I think that
ultimately if you hear enough people say
that you're too kind or too aggressive
or full of [ __ ] or whatever it is that
eventually you know I gotta stop cursing
cuz all the Facebook posts now you guys
need the beep that's extra work for you
guys
you know I think that that's the one
place that's the only hack I know I
don't think there's any other move I
think it's about getting people to tell
you about yourself in safe environments
being aggressive about that really seek
out that that feedback and then be man
enough woman enough to eat it really and
the way you get more of it is when a
friend of you says I think you're a
little fool crap you know you don't end
that relationship you triple down on
that relationship because they're giving
it to you and that's if you really want
self-awareness you need to wildly if you
want to hack self-awareness I actually
think it's predicated on on having thick
skin I think I think that is why I
really think so much of what I pull off
is predicated on how thick my skin is my
skin is thick you know
I just can handle it I just can't I hate
it I hate it I hate like reading like
you know bad stuff about me it's this
it's devastating but I respect it I can
accept it I understand it and I try to
use it as something that I go on the
offense with going forward and so
they're learning moments and so you know
if you could get over yourself right if
you know and the funny thing is like I
don't know I feel like I'm so self-aware
I'm not sure I think but I you know even
like even people that I think are not
self-aware around me it's funny to me
how self-aware they really are just you
don't
let your brain accept your shortcomings
as we owe the self-awareness video the
speed good time to click it up if you
haven't seen this this is some of the
best work who is this this is the Iraq
or Stefan so thought this is great this
was great
this was great show him it was great
shown shown great watch the video link
it up and like show a little silly you
know what do you rock end in like a
little I want 13 seconds of it your
choice go this is a word that is rarely
talked about in our space that I want to
start building more attention for self
awareness I want to deliver on this
message so much that would create a test
or or a drug that allowed people to
become self aware one potion inject not
hustle not smart self awareness I don't
fear being self aware
alright let's keep going Stephanie ass
like why is my dad following an ism like
no that's unacceptable Stephanie have
bad news every social network that you
go to to try to get away from pops when
they hit scale pops is gonna show up hey
Stephanie
it's your dad this knick-knack thing is
real cool that's what's gonna always
happen for the rest of your and by the
way let me get a little bit deeper on
that Steve you're about to say something
no something for the end of the show
hold it doing the show do it ruin the
end the show we're on Spotify what do
you mean side that I'm excited we're on
Spotify the askgaryvee show it's on
Spotify since you four emails yesterday
see it was a black and white
announcement this is a black and white
announcement we're on Spotify this was
not a color announcement this was a
black and white announcement we're on
Spotify and and Stephanie going back to
you and the entire vaynernation
soon you'll be part of it Stephanie yes
you will you know that I know it was
weird that creep Alex hit you up that
somebody answered your question on
Twitter randomly I love this whole thing
making cool Alex the creepy guy is so
fun for me um look that's what just
happens right we had happened with
Facebook it's happening right now with
Instagram the youth establishes these
new kind of community centers for our
society
and then everybody follows that's a very
interesting dynamic because I think
that's the reverse of the way human
nature has been for a very long time and
so I think that the youth culture of our
society is now establishing the main
community centers not the cot new club
that's different this isn't this is the
out-and-out community centers of our
society is going to have a very massive
long-term effects on us as humans I
think that's why we're living through a
youth of vacation that I talk a lot
about and so that's why it's happening
Stephanie Johanna says how do you
balance speed hustle and patience you
Hamas's such a great name I really like
that like Johan and Pocahontas no
seriously you weren't thinking that
that's what I was thinking I was
thinking that Johan Santana that was
dating Pocahontas and they were known as
a couple as Johan tiss Johan said
there's a real baseball player lefty and
Pocahontas is obviously Pocahontas okay
let's go obviously this is yeah yeah I
got your harness right this is the best
question because the truth is I really
believe that I'm a bridge right I'm
pulling equally very aggressively from
both sides that I'm a human
contradiction that if you really watch a
show and throws people off as they get
deeper into my content that often times
I'm saying things that contradict
themselves because the truth is they
both live in real life at the same time
and it's about finding that cadence and
balance to guide through I am massively
at a global level patient but on a
practical level and an execution level
I'm very fast right so it's it's really
it really is religion and church right
like at the highest like at the
theoretical at the at the at the gray
levels I'm patient long game I'm aware
that as long as I'm alive I'm playing
the businessman game and and and it
doesn't end tomorrow and if it ends
tomorrow I don't know the outcome anyway
because I'm dead
right and so in but in real life I
understand it's a race and the X speed
is a variable for success to me in a big
way
hustle and so the patience and speed are
very much rubbing against each other but
it's like the diamond comes from that
right like and so that's that's the
thing that I think about I don't I I
find it very easy to devote you
understand there's people that are both
in practical and philosophical terms and
they have different outcomes
aka there's people that philosophically
are not patient they're impatient and
they're fast and they look like the bad
version of what I am right there like
hustlers and they're like like doing
everything for themselves and they're
not patient they don't care about the
long game and they're just gonna take
and they're just gonna take and take and
take and gonna take fast and they're
gonna gather and and I think that that's
society the game rewards them and
there's a lot of millionaires and
billionaires that didn't do it the right
way and that's what I think they look
like then there's a lot of people that
are massively patient and slow and those
are the Norma's amount of people that
you know in a business context not in
life they're probably some of the
loveliest human beings that I've ever
been made because they're slow and their
patient and everything just lovely and
let's just like sit on the porch and you
know drink peach tea for the rest of our
lives and like like go slow just go real
slow like like let's sit and look at
stuff like like let's sit on the porch
and look like look at stuff like the car
just drove by great like I mean like
that you know it's not interesting to me
either and and so that exists so I
actually think what what I do exists a
lot I think there I think it's the
likable you know aggressive person and
that's you know they're out there and
there's a lot of winners that are good
people that I really think that I think
if you look at my analogies this beam
part is really valuable right like like
if you're speedy and selfish and
impatient you know I think the other
thing about the the lack of patience and
fast you don't have to be a bad person I
think it leads to mistakes right
that's another variable layer here you
know it's funny that my brain went that
fer
narrative here's a second narrative
you're going fast you're not patient so
you rush the outcome and you leave money
on the table you sold a company too soon
you uh you weren't as profitable as you
could have been because you missed
things because you didn't see it because
you weren't tactful and so you know I
think I think it has essence of strategy
you know somebody once said to me about
Vayner Garrett you guys are so
interesting he was trying to zing me a
little bit that we weren't strategic
enough he said you're so interesting but
he's like when you get into the house I
feel like a lot of times you guys just
run through the glass window instead of
opening the door like it was a funny
analogy and then I looked at him and
said yeah but we're gonna own all the
homes I guess that's a good way to end
it cool question of the day what are you
in India you get to ask the question
they I know you
it was gonna happen
what are your Memorial Day weekend plans
you're gonna hate it you hate it it's
almost weirdly the thing I was gonna do
but really yeah you keep asking
questions
India will keep telling me to answer
them let's do it and we come to maybe
Ternes yeah cool so let's do it
[Music]